okay
game started against the player from the
u.s
logo fed
some very high-rated 2005
but he doesn't have a name attached
okay this is unusual he simply didn't
capture here
so i am
and just develop normally don't need to
do the
castling by hand
yeah this is um really somewhat
somewhat weird but such a high rated
player white should be clearly better
already
this one is designed to prevent knight
g4 e5
well okay white should be clearly better
that said it's not
not simple black can play
all the standard moves quickly and
well he could he doesn't
okay in 98
yeah maybe trying to
harass him a bit on e7 that he cannot
easily move the queen away
i want him to to make at least some
concession
yeah okay i don't mind
this exchange
e7 is still under some under some
pressure
so you cannot easily move the screen
maybe queen d7
or knight b5 this could be
um could be an idea
not 100 sure what's the um
the correct pset up here
yeah i have some some weird idea
playing b3 knight b5 knight a4
to block the queen side maybe this is
just utter crap but i like the idea
let's try this
of course you can go knight d4 but i
have
pretty easy um way to get rid of the
knight
yeah okay i go there
can go on queen to c4 to to block this
and
knight e2 bishop e2 e3 to
exchange the knight off so
the idea basically is that this knight
makes his two rooks looking stupid
so maybe he needs to reposition the rook
somehow and then i can maybe get the
knight back into play
this is of course a strong piece but
right now it
it doesn't do anything too terrible
next moves would be rook c1 rook c2
to to cover all the stuff here c4
f2 and then maybe try slowly to to push
forward
so
if the circumstances are
alright i can even consider an exchange
sacrifice
okay he he sacrifices himself
which is
not unusual wants to get some activity
going
yeah this is um not easy to play this
bishop is a really
fantastic piece of course
how do i make progress here it's not
easy at all
i know rook a3
i just yeah i didn't see it rook a3 g3
just easily um getting a good position
okay
h4 is not not a bad move
but
time warning
yeah g3 um g3 was just a
complete lemon i i shouldn't really lose
this
he's got compensation for the exchange
but uh
it's not not easy to improve the
position at all and this is just
just crap here maybe just
just plain lost
i cannot can i do much he just wins this
pawns and
now he's got a winning position
they are terrible okay i'm pretty sign
this is just just too awful
yeah i think black was just completely
outplayed here
and this was really his last chance to
to get something here
and it's just a question if this is
enough form
if i if i don't do anything here i can
never lose this game
of course but it's it's really a
questionable how how to make progress so
yeah difficult maybe i overestimated
this a bit it's very really difficult to
to play here and this is maybe
compensation
for for black maybe it is
of course you can just play rook a3 and
take on g3
he didn't see this played h4
but it's still still a bad position
g3 is just the position doesn't really
yeah but i don't have any great plan on
improving here so
maybe um maybe i need to play somewhere
else here
maybe i lost too much time this is
possible
play more
more exact moves here i just need
one or two moves to uh to get this um
exchange sacrifice out of this
out of the position so maybe maybe
something like rook c1 queen d1 rook c4
or something
i pray and prevent this then i can can
slowly make progress
yeah difficult really difficult
and this is just just difficult to play
in a practical game
bishop is really terribly strong
yeah this is i think compensation maybe
really for black
yeah this kind of positions are
difficult
or difficult of course yeah i still like
this idea it's it's not
unusual at all in the benko
but some yeah what can you do
play a new game i guess okay